let me ask the last
yeah big ridiculous question uh so
you've lived
much of your life your career is kind of
at the edge of life and death
so um let me ask kind of uh
several different ways the same kind of
question one
d do you have you pondered your
mortality the finiteness of it
and the bigger question to ask even in
the context of
your uh tic tac encounter
is uh what do you think is the meaning
of this uh thing we got going on here
the meaning of life human life in this
sense
so let me start with have i pondered my
own mortality yes
quite often um and i don't get into my
religious beliefs or what i am
but i will tell you that i do believe in
god i've just
seen too many things in the world that i
can't explain
and some people will explain it by
subconscious so i'll give you a story
and this kind of puts in the thing of
do i fear death so i had a good friend
of mine that i used to fly with we were
stationed in japan together and
japan had this incinerator that put all
kinds of dioxins so there's a real high
cancer rate for those that served on the
base
in atsugi japan
him and his wife had one son and their
son
passed away just before his 18th
birthday of cancer
and i was hanging out with i'll call him
john
and i was hanging out with john we were
in oil and gas he had come to the same
company and
we were doing an event together and he
was opening up to me
because we were actually the demo pilots
we do the demonstration for air shows
and stuff
and him and i were sitting there talking
and uh
he was giving me the whole story and and
how he had it really changed his look on
life
that we're only here for a finite time
and that we're all going to die
well unfortunately after all that when
it was really going him and his wife had
moved to
a location that would fit their you know
close to the water where they could do
stuff and i won't say where um and he
was doing what he loved to do
and he got diagnosed with throat cancer
and i was talking to him uh it was
probably about
maybe two months before he died um
and i said dude hey you're sad you mean
this is your friend
and i'm kind of really bummed out and
this is the guy
this is a guy that's dying of cancer and
here's what he tells me he says
dave dude we're all gonna die
he goes but i have to look at it i have
to make the best of the time that i have
and i said i understand that he goes
with the exception
of not being with my wife who he loved
dearly
he goes i'm okay with dying
i've had a really good life and
um about
because actually the original
announcement when he when he finally
passed away a buddy of mine called me
because i don't do facebook and his wife
had put it on facebook that he had
passed
and about the day before he died for
some reason i was thinking about him
and i had a dream right i think it was a
dream
or an altered reality you can get into
whatever uh
but he was there it was just him and i
and i was really sad in the dream i was
actually crying
and he was there and he was actually in
his uniform he was in his whites and
uh because he's a navy and we were just
talking and he looked at me and he said
and this is in my dream he's like dave
it's all going to be okay and this is
this is like and this is a vivid
conversation i have there's
people gonna think i'm weird about this
um but you know i know what
my dream was and you know maybe it's my
subconscious creating the dream but
in in reality to me this was real that
it was put there for a reason
he's and he basically explained
everything he's it's okay
i'm gonna be fine my wife is fine he
goes this is this is what's meant to be
you know but you know and the bottom
line was make use of every day that you
have because you don't know
and literally two days later i find out
that he passed
um so but ultimately
he accepted the finiteness of it he did
well you have to
and it's like i talk about you know
money and job position and this and that
i said you can get in any you know you
can go to a company
just remember when you want to be a vp
of a company you sell your soul to the
company
you have to i said if you look i joke
with people at work and i said
i said you know when you ever think that
you're important or this guy has that i
said when you're sitting on 93 or 95 128
and you're sitting in traffic and we're
stopped which doesn't happen right now
because of covet but normally it's stop
it's bumper to bumper and you're sitting
here
like i was coming down here by the gas
tank um
when you're sitting there look left and
look right you know and there can be a
a lamborghini or an s550 mercedes and on
the other side there could be some piece
of crap car
we're all sitting on the same freeway at
the same time trying to do the same
thing which is just get home so we can
be with our family because the most
important thing that we have
it ain't money it ain't our job it's not
our position i go because when it's all
said and done
you could be you know you can be with
the exception of the presidents of the
united states i mean
name the vice presidents most people
can't
and eventually they're going to die or
eventually you're going to see a statue
of a guy from the 1700s in the boston
area and you're going to go i don't even
know who that guy was
did he impact my life he probably did
but eventually people forget
yeah you realize what's important now
and the one thing that you have
is your family and your close friends
and that's that's
it you can take all the money or
everything else if you're down on your
luck
you know who is going to be a we is joke
who are your true friends
it's the person while there's there's
ones that i won't say but you know hey
you're broke down on a road in the
middle of nowhere and it's three o'clock
in the morning who you going to call is
going to get in their car without
complaining and come and get you
and that's life those that is life the
people you love
it's it's it's the people you truly care
about and contrary to i have you know oh
my god i got 6 000 facebook friends
you got about that many real friends
that you can count on
and that's it everything else doesn't
matter no it doesn't matter it doesn't
mean you might be nice i mean i have
there's acquaintance friends that i'll
do anything for and they can come to my
house and stuff but then there's the
people that you know
you know like my cousins who are like my
brothers that you know
at a moment's notice you know when
when my uncle passed away at a young age
you know
who lived literally right down the
street from me and my cousin chad
and i got two boys there's 14 of us but
there's only two boys there's three of
us together and we all grew up in the
same neighborhood same schools
play football together all that i said
if one of those if rare chad ever needs
me
if something happens like when my uncle
died it wasn't it wasn't an issue if i'm
coming home
it's i'm booking the ticket i don't give
a [ __ ] what it costs because i will be
there
to be here with you and and then those
two
guys and my college roommate is another
one that i'm very very close with
you know you know if there's
there's i have a handful of people that
you know i will drop literally
everything
even if my wife would be pissed at me at
times she's like seriously i gotta do it
yeah and now she knows and it's the same
thing with her i mean she knows that
there are certain people in her life
that if they really need her and she has
to go she would go and i would let her
go
so given all that i'm
honored that you would uh come here and
talk to me
and take the time dave it was one of the
best conversations i've ever had
thank you so much it's a pretty long one
this probably sets the record for the
longest one
so i i mean
i'm a loss of war is one of my favorite
conversations thank you so much for
talking to you dave you're welcome
you